tell me if you need me to bring up the
videos and replay them
can you tell me
what type of makeup amber heard was
wearing in any of those videos
the hollow cameras i can't tell you
you know
[Music]
can you tell me whether amber heard was
wearing concealer in any of those videos
no
can you tell me whether amber heard was
wearing any foundation in any of those
videos
can you tell me whether amber heard was
wearing any blush in any of those videos
no
can you tell me whether amber heard was
wearing any powder on in any of those no
no but
she looks really pale
well
do you know what shade of concealer or
foundation or powder ms bird uses or
used at that time
no
okay
um so you don't know whether ms heard
was wearing makeup in every one of those
video clips correct
all right
enough i want to try to move along so
the incident was may 21st 2016.
you saw her the night of may 25th
correct
she said
amber heard hundreds
treat you well and was she friendly to
you in each of these hundreds of times
yes yes i i'm not gonna say no because
she was really always nice
right
be nice all right this is my last
question you testified in response to mr
presidio's questions um that you
testified truthfully in all of these
occasions did you testify truthfully
truthfully to everything that you
testified in response to my questions
today
that's correct um i i did
that was the first i'm sorry
i will say your own that is the most
bizarre episode yeah okay all right
see i've just never seen that before
i've seen a lot of things but i've just
never seen driving that yeah that did it